- This is a hard one because the last one
seems very fake but you've been being
kind of a tricky bastard.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
(logo whooshes)
(hinge squeaks)
(upbeat electronic music)
- First of all, they're all reasonable.
- I'm gonna go manicure station.
- Might be the chicken,
though, 'cause like, what,
just randomly gonna be good in every city?
Doubtful.
- It seems like the
obvious fake one that why
I'm not going with it.
- [Man On Right] I'm gonna go with A.
- So you're saying
chicken, you're saying C?
- [Man On Left] Mm-hmm (affirmative).
- I'll say B.
(buzzes)
You tricked me on purpose.
- You just took the default
of the one that nobody
had chosen.
- [Man On Right] It's not about you.
(upbeat electronic music)
- [Man on Right] B.
- [Man on Left] B.
(buzzes)
I'd be fine with a new Tabasco bottle--
- We weren't fucking born yesterday.
- But I would not be fine with tomatoes
and I would not be fine with
them not individually wrapped.
(upbeat electronic music)
- I'm gonna go boxers.
- Barber's chair.
- I'm gonna go masseuse.
- Shit.
(buzzes)
- Fuck, I got a fucking--
- That's what I picked.
- [Man on Left] Well, I was wrong.
- So you were correct.
Did you really pick it?
- Yes.
- Did you pick boxers?
- No, I picked masseuse.
- They can just run the tape back.
- I'm gonna go boxers.
I'm gonna go boxers.
Boxers.
(upbeat electronic music)
- We already know that's real
because we worked with her.
- We've worked with her so that's real.
I'm gonna say two, B.
- [Man on Right] Yeah.
(buzzes)
- [Man on Left] What?
- But she did make sure that
the temperature was, and
she didn't bring a rug.
- [Man on Right] Wow.
- She wanted a vibe.
- We had to wear bags over our heads.
- We did not have to do anything weird.
- No.
- [Man on Left] We did have to wear a bag.
- [Man In Middle] Of course, obviously.
(upbeat electronic music)
- I'm gonna go the socks
because socks come in one size.
- Ben & Jerry's is just
odd 'cause he's so thin--
- [Man on Left] Fit.
- [Man on Right] Yeah.
- I kinda want it now that
we're talking about it.
- [Man on Right] Me and
(mumbles) are going socks.
What are you doing?
- [Man on Left] Yeah, we're going socks.
- Well, I'm way behind so I'm gonna say A.
I don't even remember what it was.
(buzzes)
Fuck!
- [Man on Left] Extra small sock.
- Maybe he uses them
to keep his nards warm.
- Oh, that could be, like
a Chili Peppers thing.
- Yeah, but just the
nards, yeah, no one's nards
are as big as a foot.
- I can't believe you
just admitted on tape
that your nards are not that small.
- Your nards are as big as a foot?
- Yes.
- That's disgusting, what's our rider?
- [Man on Left] We don't
have one, I don't think.
- [Man In Middle] Yeah we do, like mango--
- We have one?
I thought it was just stuff
we like but not demands.
(logo whooshes)
(hinge squeaks)